-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we are gonna
get to the news.
President Biden addressed the
UN General Assembly yesterday
and said that the Russian
invasion of Ukraine
"is about extinguishing
Ukraine's right
to exist as a state,"
and nine out of 10 times,
I agree we shouldn't do that.
[ Laughter ]
In the same speech,
President Biden addressed
the ongoing invasion in Ukraine
and said, "Russia has shamefully
violated the core tenets
of the United Nations Charter,
not to mention the dress code.
[ Laughter ]
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
addressed the
UN General Assembly yesterday
in a pre-recorded speech,
and it must have been
very pre-recorded,
'cause he said,
"Everything's great."
[ Laughter ]
The House yesterday
voted 229 to 203
to overhaul
the Electoral Count Act.
Though, somehow
that wasn't a majority.
[ Laughter ]
Always put math in the jokes.
People love to do that math.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden issued
a major disaster declaration
yesterday for Puerto Rico,
but thankfully Governor DeSantis
is already sending help.
[ Laughter ]
In an interview
on Fox News last night,
former President Trump defended
his handling
of sensitive materials
and said that he had the power
to declassify documents
"even by thinking about it."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, great.
So, on top of everything else,
Trump has The Shining.
Well...
[ Laughter ]
...that explains
his luck with hotels.
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
former President Trump claimed
that the agents who raided
his Mar-a-Lago home
took his will and said it could
"cause a lot of problems
if it's published,"
'cause not everyone
made the cut.
[ Laughter ]
A banner was raised
in Madison Square Garden
last night celebrating...
[ Women cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
Get it out of your system.
He's not here.
[ Laughter ]
He's not gonna see this.
He's not gonna know you cheered.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
And, by the way, buddy,
if you are watching,
I'm so sorry I said that.
We'd love to have you.
If you're in your hotel
after a concert right now
relaxing with "Late Night"
and you just saw that joke,
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
A banner was raised
in Madison Square Garden
last night celebrating Harry
Styles' 15 nights of concerts.
"Plenty of room up there,"
said Knicks fans.
[ Laughter ]
World champs -- 1973.
Harry Styles.
[ Laughter ]
Today was the first day of fall,
and due to climate change, this
is how the leaves are changing.
That was taken in Vermont.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Taco Bell has announced
that it will begin testing
its new meatless carne asada
next month at dozens
of locations in Dayton, Ohio,
raising the question --
how many Taco Bells
does Dayton, Ohio, need?
[ Laughter ]
But true story --
I tried to book a flight
to Dayton today
after I heard this news,
and they were available.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody!